it's just going to be a little bit tight
okay okay
Louise Smith has been asked to get a
blood test
okay sharp scratch her doctors are
worried about a family history of
diabetes
[Music]
the health secretary wants patients like
Louise to never wait more than two weeks
for a GP appointment and if they're
really sick be seen on the day
I think for minor like illnesses it's
two weeks is I think is fair
urgent is you know I think it should be
dealt with straight away I mean when
I've had
urgent cases I would actually just go to
a e
tree's coffee says she'll help Primary
Care with more nurses support staff and
better telephone systems but doctors
like Ravi Toma say that alone won't help
a Health Service on its knees
all statistics all research all the
actual data suggests that general
practice very much is on the back foot
on its knees at Breaking Point not to
say there's not easy things in quick
wins that we can do to help that and in
long term things that we can do to try
and address that as well
one doctor's group warns the healthcare
crisis is so bad one in four people
could be left without a GP within a
decade
GPS agree patient access must be made an
urgent priority but what they don't want
to see are more targets without being
given the help they need to manage
growing patient registers and GB
practices hemorrhaging doctors
problems accessing the Right Care at the
right time stretch well beyond general
practice Jenny Morgan is still in agony
after a missed fracture and delays to
her treatments they ruined my life I was
able to do things I was able to do the
garden do the shopping look after the
house
I can't do any of that now
and I'd love to do the garden and you
know instead of pay somebody to do it
I'd love to walk the dogs somebody else
has to do all these things hello
and it's patients like Jenny that the
health secretary wants better care for
she rejects criticism that her plans
fail to address the workforce issues
that are driving NHS precious
I'm standing up here for patients um
focused on my ABCD because that's what
most people experience getting access to
a doctor getting access to a dentist
having an ambulance turn up on time
rather than be stuck in in terms of
being stuck outside a hospital those are
the things that matter when people need
care the most and that's what I'll keep
my focus on
the health secretary and Healthcare
leaders want the same thing better care
for patients the challenge is to find
the best way to deliver that care in a
system Under Pressure like never before
oh she's Joshy Sky News